Birds of Prey is soaring to new heights.
Just before its release this Friday, director
Cathy Yan's Birds of Prey (and the Fantabulous
Emancipation of One Harley Quinn) is earning
rave reviews from critics, whose responses
have been officially recorded on Rotten Tomatoes
- and it's become clear that critics truly
enjoyed their time with Harley Quinn and her
gang of misfits.
As of Thursday, February 6, Birds of Prey
holds an excellent 89 percent approval rating
on the review aggregator site.
With Academy Award nominee Margot Robbie leading
Birds of Prey as Harley, the role she first
played in 2016's Suicide Squad, the film puts
the colorful criminal's narrative firmly in
her own hands, telling the story of Harley's
alliance with several other powerful women
to save a young girl named Cassandra Cain
from the wicked Black Mask and his psychotic
sidekick Victor Zsasz.
Joining Harley to form the Birds of Prey gang
are Huntress, Renee Montoya, and Black Canary.
As one of the most anticipated films of the
first half of 2020 and another entry into
the female superhero canon, Birds of Prey
is seemingly set to follow in the footsteps
of critical successes like fellow DCEU flick
Wonder Woman and the MCU's Captain Marvel
– which is certainly encouraging as comic
book studios start to create more diverse
stories for all types of fans.
And, according to Rotten Tomatoes, those fans
are over the moon.
The general critical consensus on Birds of
Prey so far seems to be that above all else,
the movie is just plain ol' fun.
Over at Time Out, Helen O'Hara opened her
review by saying the, quote, "story [is] scrappy,
weird, and ultimately fun as hell."
She went on to conclude:
"Birds of Prey isn't interested in hitting
all the usual superhero movie beats.
It works because we haven't seen this story
a thousand times before, and because it leaves
behind the grim-dark posturing of Suicide
Squad.
It's nice to see a joker who doesn't take
herself too seriously."
Meanwhile, Culture Whisper's Ella Kemp wrote:
"Birds of Prey fizzes with madness, violence,
and blistering fun.
Harley Quinn has always been an agent of chaos
- which is why her and the Joker were so well-suited
- and her standalone film lets this madness
run wild from the off."
Owen Gleiberman of Variety praised director
Cathy Yan for her keen eye and good taste
in music.
He wrote:
"Directing her first studio feature, Cathy
Yan keeps it all hurtling along with impeccable
ferocity.
Her action scenes have a deftly detonating
visual spaciousness, capped by crowd-pleasing
moments like the one where Harley, brandishing
a baseball bat, ricochets it off the ground
with perfect slow-mo timing.
And Yan sprinkles just the right songs [...] through
what feels like a music-video comic-book jamboree,
one that effectively taps into timely undercurrents
of feminine rage."
"I love this chick.
She's got rage issues—"
"I don't have rage issues!"
Writing for IndieWire, Kate Erbland argued
that while the film is perhaps a little too
ambitious, it works in the end, noting that
the film marks, quote, "a necessary reinvention
that adds dimension and depth to one of the
DC Expanded Universe's most distinctive characters."
She added:
"It may not be the promised total emancipation
(at least not yet), but it is fantabulous
in its own way."
Obviously, Birds of Prey enjoyed largely positive
reviews upon its release - but some critics
weren't completely crazy about Harley's wild
ride.
John Defore of The Hollywood Reporter accused
the film of following all the rules it claims
to break.
He wrote:
"Those hoping for a Deadpool-like fusion of
mayhem and wit should lower their expectations:
Harley may be known for her unpredictability,
but Birds plays by action-movie rules."
Over at Vulture, Allison Willmore said the
film provides, quote, "mixed results" as it,
quote, "attempts to pry Harley away from the
dysfunctional relationship that has defined
her and let her fly free with her own sparkle-and
shattered-limb-filled adventure."
She continued:
"If the results are mixed, it's because the
movie devotes more thought to putting distance
between itself and Suicide Squad than to imagining
what an independent version of the character
is actually like."
Willmore wrapped up her review by describing
Harley Quinn as a, quote, "character too beloved
to be abandoned and too confounding to be
solved."
However, the harshest Birds of Prey review
thus far seems to be from The San Francisco
Chronicle's Mick LaSalle, who didn't mince
any words.
His take?
"Birds of Prey [...] is more than horrible.
It should not exist.
Money should never have been raised for it.
The screenplay should never have been filmed.
Margot Robbie shouldn't have produced it.
She certainly shouldn't have starred in it.
It's just a terrible thing to inflict on audiences,
who, after all, didn't hurt anyone and just
hoped to have a nice time."
“Y'know, psychologically speaking, vengeance
rarely brings the catharsis we hope for."
"Yeah…"
All in all, it's encouraging that this female-led
film is packing a punch, especially after
this iteration of Harley Quinn made her debut
in the largely mediocre Suicide Squad.
With most critics praising the film and just
a handful shooting it down, it seems like
Birds of Prey will fly high upon its release.
But, as always, fans will need to form their
own opinions when the film opens in theaters
on Friday, February 7.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.